It's a rainy day in London.
We haven't playtested this at all.
I have no idea if this is gonna work,
but this is Arun from Mrwhosetheboss.
Hello.
And you have an AirTag.
I do. So this is basically
a low-power Bluetooth tracker,
and I'm gonna stick it in Tom's pocket
and see if I can find you.
The producers have put together
a list of things to do in London.
I've got one hour from when I see that list
to do as much of it as I can.
And all Arun has to do
is catch me.
How confident are you?
I feel great, 'cause I just realised
Tom has an iPhone,
and these things get their location
by pinging off iPhones.
So every time I open this up
for Google Maps...
I'm gonna know where you are.
Every time I walk past someone
with any Apple device...
Yep.
Alright, it's in the pocket.
One hour on the clock,
and I've got a three-minute head start.
This is now—
Are you stretching?!
This is gonna look
rough and ready because...
all we have on cameras here are
one GoPro for each of us following.
So... if you wanna get the timer ready.
Yep.
One hour.
Three, two, one, go.
Two, one, tap.
Guh!
Aaaah!
Ohh, I'm so scared.
Okay, so we gotta give him three minutes.
He's a fast runner.
Right, so I've only got three minutes
before he's on the move.
So, first step is go underground...
where this isn't gonna work
right away.
As soon as
he turns his phone off,
we're gonna struggle
to track him as accurately.
It's not updating.
Tom!
"Dance to a busker.
Take a selfie with Sherlock."
Oh blimey,
there's so many things here!
This is a lot of challenges, though!
Closest one is— right—
"feed the ducks at a Royal Park."
I'm gonna need something—
"Salute a guard at Buckingham Palace."
We're going to Buckingham Palace.
That's happening.
Okay so, I'm gonna check the list
to see where he's going.
Green Park. I need Green Park.
Three minutes feels like
such a long time!
This requires London geography.
He's had several minutes to think,
whereas I just panicked and ran,
and I think...
that might've been a bad idea.
I'm gonna have to Google
a lot of these things.
The good news is,
as soon as I'm on this train,
he's not gonna get this train,
and he's not gonna be able to track me.
But... he'll know that I'm on the Tube.
He's in the station.
He's in the station!
Okay... but where's he going?
Oh, we should probably
get started, alright.
(giggles)
Could you imagine if
we got on the same train as him?
This is some much-needed cardio.
The Tube is so fast, and yet
feels so slow right now.
This is incredibly frustrating.
On the bright side though,
it's part of this game
that Tom can only use each form
of public transport once.
I don't think it's gonna be, like,
that accurate tracking.
I trust these AirTags.
Whoops. Sorry. Excuse me.
So the reason I picked
Covent Garden is I think,
quite a few things on this list
he could do there.
It feels like candidate number one.
"Feed the ducks. Mimic a statue."
There will be a statue
in Covent Garden.
Not my stop, is it?
Okay, easy first point:
imitate a statue.
This is where London knowledge
comes in handy!
Two more stops.
Might as well get a seat.
What've we got?
We got... facing this way...
Gonna be using these.
Turn that way.
That, it turns out,
is a very, very difficult position.
Do you think that's close enough?
Do I get the point?
This hand, this way.
Yeah.
Good enough. That's one.
This way.
He could go on the bus, but...
you're almost faster
walking in London.
He could take a bike.
He's a bit of a rogue character.
Tom Scott can do anything(!)
I did not realise...
quite how paranoid I'd be,
how quickly.
Because... this is...
I know, like, worst case,
absolute worst case,
he's one train behind me.
But this is...
a very big, open space.
And I am now very trackable.
Alright, Tom Scott.
I'm coming for you.
Or maybe we're on the
other side of London. We'll find out.
Agh. Have I got time...?
"To the stairs."
I don't have time.
Is this an exit? I don't know!
Alright.
What is this? (groans)
Buckingham Palace.
(breathless) The pain, the pain!
Tom! What've you done to me, Tom?
Guard. Guard.
Me, guard.
Two.
(panting heavily)
Now I realise I shoulda...
I shoulda taken the lift.
(wheezes exhaustedly)
I don't suppose you have any...
Don't suppose you got
any snacks on you
for duck feeding or
anything like that, have you?
'Cause...
(laughs)
Is it okay to feed
a Milky Way bar to ducks?
Okay. So we're in Covent Garden now.
But let's check the AirTag location.
Hopefully he is here.
Hey Siri, can ducks eat chocolate?
So the AirTag is still putting
his location as the Underground,
which means...
he might not have got
out of the train yet.
Got an answer.
It's displayed on your iPhone.
Why are you giving me
the nutrition information for a duck?!
What do we do now then?
What if he's just doing
a lap of London?
Even with me being sceptical of
how good the AirTag is...
Arun must have got a location.
He must know I'm in this area by now.
So... let's get a...
Let's feed a duck and get out.
That is a pigeon.
My confidence levels are dropping.
(wheezes)
That is a crow.
That's a goose.
There's gotta be a duck
around here somewhere.
Tom is not updating. No.
You know what he's done? He's probably
turned his phone on airplane mode.
"Chocolate is toxic to livestock like ducks."
Nnnngh, that looks like a shop!
That's a coot. Those are swans.
Those are geese.
Where are the ducks?!
Today on "I Identify Birds"(!)
So the issue is, if Tom has
put his phone on airplane mode,
then we can't rely on the AirTag to
constantly ping his location from his iPhone.
So we've instead gotta wait for him
to pass other people with iPhones
for that AirTag to ping
the location off them.
Let's just go towards the water
and hope he pops up.
Yes, I got a receipt.
This is a business expense.
(giggles)
This is a business-expense
slice of carrot cake.
Where are the ducks?
There are the ducks.
Water's our best shot.
We just gotta outrun him.
Do I see Arun anywhere?
I don't— I don't see him.
Oh, okay. It's updated.
Queen Victoria Memorial.
He's not far, he's not far!
Duck Island is where he is.
He's feeding the ducks, he is!
Duck, duck.
Go on. That's a point.
So it looks like
Tom's managed to sneak in
a cheeky little duck feeding session
on the way down.
But we're gonna cut him off
before he gets to the Thames.
This way.
St. James Park station.
Also, do you want some carrot cake?
I'd love some carrot cake.
There we go.
Okay, he's moving.
I can see him moving.
That's pretty good carrot cake.
(muffled) It's not bad.
Hi, can we go to Westminster station, please?
What can we get around here?
I can't take the Tube again, so...
"Cross the Thames.
Visit a famous boat."
There must be a tourist tat shop there
where I can get a stupid hat.
"Change one item of clothing."
Alright. South.
Oh, also parakeets.
YouTube guy. I know you.
Yeah.
Also in the middle of a chase game right now.
But... enjoy the parakeets!
So three of these tasks involve
this river right here,
and we're basically guarding the waterway
to make sure he doesn't get these done.
I just know there's gonna be...
somewhere in this video...
there's gonna be just this...
devastating shot out of a cab window,
as he goes down past there.
I'm paranoid of every cab now.
Okay, it's just updated again.
He's that way.
Right.
Oh, he's updated.
Strand? Apparently that's close!
Okay.
I don't see him. I don't see him.
Okay, I think the world's smallest
police station is around here.
I don't see him. I don't see him.
Point and run!
Hmm.
Probably there.
I still don't see him. Okay.
Who said you can't cover
London on foot?
Okay, there are two choices.
Wtih the time left, there's only
two, maybe three I can get.
"Cross the Thames."
"Recite a line of Shakespeare
at the Globe."
That's down there, but that's a long way.
Or "buy a gift for Arun from Covent Garden."
That's a time-waster.
"Change one item of clothing."
So that's two in Covent Garden.
And then... cross the Thames from there.
Covent Garden.
It's right there. It's right there.
I hate to say this, but I think
it may be time to run again.
(groans) Traffic!
Here we go.
We're as close as we've been,
right now.
Alright, I need to buy a gift for Arun.
I need to get a bit of clothing for myself.
I should really go to the Apple Store
and get him an AirTag,
but I think he's already got
about ten of them.
Okay wait. This way.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Is it possible to get a
printed receipt though, please?
Yes.
Thank you.
This is the team's new
production office,
where all the prep for all the videos
on this channel happens.
And this is the new office decoration
that I'm putting up today,
thanks to Displate,
who are sponsoring this video.
Displate make posters made of
beautifully-printed metal...
which elevates these way above anything
you'd normally find on an office wall.
And the mounting system
uses fancy magnets,
so you don't need any tapes or hammers
or power tools to put them up.
You just... put them in place.
You can also use their new
3D magnets
to make it seem like the poster's
hovering away from the wall.
These are the medium-sized ones,
which fit nicely on the panels here.
They're also available in larger sizes
and framed up, if you like,
in either gloss or matte,
to fit your wall.
For the office, we went for
the light map of London,
which looks spectacular
printed up on metal like this,
and...
this beautiful bit of art
by Frank Moth.
They've also got officially licensed posters
from Star Wars, Marvel, DC,
and a load of movies and video games.
And I also got this print of
NASA's Grand Tour design
from the Jet Propulsion Laboratory.
But I'm taking this one home.
You can go to the link in the
video description to get a discount,
and to see the Displates
that the team and I here recommend.
Right. Back to the show.
Right, okay. Got him a gift.
I am now terrified that he has...
while I was in there,
talking to the wonderfully chatty—
but unfortunately, that's not
what I really want at that moment—
the unfortunately chatty
shop assistant—
that he ran by, got the photo,
and moved on,
and is now tracking me.
We've gotta find him at least.
We gotta just see Tom Scott.
He's like a mirage at this point.
Come on, let's go.
Where are all the tourist tat shops?
London Transport Museum.
If he's found me by now,
I'm done for.
Thank you,
and can I get a receipt please?
Do I see him? Can I see him?
I don't see him anywhere.
I'm gonna sneak down this corner.
And...
On the assumption
he hasn't got eyes on me right now...
I hate this hat. But nevertheless...
that's, I think, a point.
Oh god. (pants heavily)
My London geography's terrible.
If I'd known this, I would have revised!
Am I going the wrong way?
I think I'm going the wrong way.
If Arun's smart...
and he's tracking me...
then he'll see me going south.
There's only... only one
possible route I could be taking now.
I think... I think?
If I've missed a really obvious strategy,
it's gonna be really annoying.
Look how close we are.
Come on, Tom. Come on.
Anywhere here.
I just wanna see him at this point.
Will it be quicker
to find a bus stop up there?
There's the bus stop. Alright.
Bus stop, south.
That'll be...
Should be... quicker overall...?
I am watching you, Tom.
I'm ready.
Any bus going to Waterloo?
Literally any bus from this stop.
No, hang on.
1, 188, 68, 168,
59, 243...
1, that bus'll do!
Literally any person here
could be him.
He's moved a little bit more.
Let's go, let's run.
(sighs heavily)
Oh, do you(?)
I'd like to think I've made
smart decisions in this game.
And I really...
I really don't think I have.
No. Oh, wait.
Can't tell, is that him?
This is a bad decision.
This was such a bad—
Every— Every other bus is going by.
I should've got off this one.
We are literally one minute away from him.
Come on, we have eight minutes left.
We've got to do this.
Okay. Okay, we're moving.
We're moving.
We're almost on top of him.
We should have playtested this.
He was last seen here
four minutes ago.
Come on, give me something.
Give me something.
Somewhere down here.
I don't see him.
I don't see him. I don't see him.
I'm still wearing
this stupid hat, aren't I?
Uhhh... I don't know!
Okay, let's assume river.
Let's go.
Waterloo Bridge, South Bank.
The Globe is...
hopefully seven minutes' run that way.
Here we go.
Ah, he could be on a bus!
There is not a way down here!
See, if he is actually sat on a bus,
and he's not near anyone
who has an Apple device,
we've got no chance.
I'll see you at the Globe.
Or on the way there!
This was a bad plan!
This was a very bad plan.
I should've got a taxi!
You... idiot!
Might as well spend my last minute
enjoying the sights of London.
From my side...
I've learned...
...that my planning
under pressure is awful!
Genuinely awful!
(chuckles)
What's it, like—
a million Apple devices in this city?
And that... is time.
(alarm rings)
Oh no, is that my gift?
Got you a gift.
Oh no!
(both laugh)
I've never been so upset
to receive something.
It was so close!
And... also...
Thank you.
In a change of pocket, an AirTag.
Aww.
Did you just guess
where I was going on the Tube?
Yeah, we had to, because the whole time,
we were three minutes behind.
Yeah.
And because AirTags
don't give you direction,
we just kinda had to
use your rough—
And you had to look at the list and work out,
"Okay, he's probably going to hit those."
Yeah.
Okay so, you could've
followed me home with it,
but you can't live-stalk someone with it.
Exactly that. That's what I was thinking.
In theory,
it should be really accurate,
because there's, like,
a billion devices around the world.
Yeah.
But, I guess in practice,
when you're moving fast,
maybe it doesn't have the—
Actively trying not to be found(!)
With a load of walls, they're gonna
bounce GPS stuff off everything.
That's also true.
Yeah.
I guess the other thing
I was thinking is...
This doesn't necessarily prove
that it's not a good tracking device,
because this time, you were aware
that I put one on you.
Oh, if I wasn't—
The number of times I was going,
"Is he— Where— Run—
I'm going— No—
I'm by the wall here.
I'm gonna stay out of the way."
I was convinced multiple times
that you were just hiding
behind somewhere, ready.
I am looking forward to
seeing this back,
and seeing just how close you got.
Yeah, me too.
This was great.
Thank you very much, man.
Alright, see ya.
(cackles)
Don't wander off now.
We can go to the pub!
(laughs) Oh yeah.
[Caption+ by JS*
caption.plus | @caption_plus]